everything we've done so far has been uh
stationary fluids or our static fluids
and we've been dealing with static
pressure because all of the you know we
we were trying to figure out what
happens when everything's in a steady
state so now let's work on what happens
when the fluid is actually moving so
let's imagine a pipe
let me draw a pipe
let's say one end of the pipe has a
larger area than the other end or at
least a different area
let me draw
so this is one end of the pipe
and that's the other end of a pipe
i didn't draw it that well and let's say
it's filled with some fluid some liquid
actually
in our example
so you know there's just a bunch of
there's just a bunch of liquid in this
fluid
right
and let's say
let's see
let's say the this area
at the entrance is the area let's call
that the area in
area in that's the area the the area of
the opening
into the pipe and let's call this area
area
out
area of the opening coming out of the
pipe
so let's think about what happen what
happens if this this liquid is actually
moving
and let's say it's moving into the pipe
with the velocity v in
right
let's think about how much volume moves
into the pipe after t seconds
so after t seconds if you think about it
every
you'd have this much area
and then if you think about what was
right here it will then be moved to the
right by how much
well what's
we could just go back to our our basic
kinematic formula distance is equal to
rate times time
so the distance something travels is
equals equals velocity times time so
after t seconds so t seconds
after t seconds whatever fluid was here
and it would have an area of about that
much whatever fluid was there would have
traveled how much to the right it would
have traveled
let's assume that the
the pipe doesn't change too much in in
in diameter or in radius from here to
here
it would have traveled
velocity times time so v in
times time
it could be meters or whatever whatever
my our length units are
so after t seconds essentially this much
water has traveled into the pipe right
you can kind of imagine a cylinder of
water here and once again i
i know i made it look like it's getting
wider the whole time but let's assume
that its width doesn't change that much
over over the t seconds or whatever
units of time we're working at right
so what is the volume of this cylinder
of water so the volume in
the volume in
over those seconds
right over the t seconds is equals to
equal to the area or kind of the the top
or the left-hand side of the cylinder
let me draw the cylinder in a more
vibrant color so you can figure out what
the
we're trying to figure out the volume of
so it equals
this side the
the left side of the cylinder
the input
area
times the length of the cylinder and
that's the velocity of the fluid times
the time that we're measuring times the
input velocity
times
time
right that's the amount of volume that
came in
and now if that volume came into the
pipe and once again we we learned
several videos ago that the definition
of a liquid is a fluid that's
incompressible right so it's not like
you know no fluid could come out of the
pipe and and all of the fluid just gets
squeezed the same volume of fluid would
have to come out of the pipe right so
that must equal the volume out
the volume out
right
so whatever whatever comes into the pipe
has to equal the volume coming out of
the pipe and one assumption we're
assuming is
in in this in this fraction of time that
we're dealing with is also that there's
no friction in this in this liquid or in
this fluid that it actually you know it
doesn't it's not turbulent and it's it's
not viscous uh a viscous fluid is really
just something that has a lot of
friction with itself and that it won't
just naturally um move without any
resistance and so when something is not
viscous and has no resistance with
itself and just moves freely without any
turbulence that's called laminar flow
and that's just a good word to
to to know about
and that's the opposite of of viscous
flow and you know different things have
different viscosities we'll probably do
more on that like syrup has a very syrup
or peanut butter has a very very high
viscosity even glass actually is a fluid
with very very high viscosity while um i
don't know i think there's there are
some kinds of compounds and magnetic
fields that you could create that are
perfect laminar flow but this is this is
kind of
a perfect situation
but anyway in these circumstances the
volume in because the fluid can't be
compressed it's incompressible has to
equal the volume out right well what's
the volume out over that period of time
well
similarly we could draw this bigger
cylinder
right that's the area out
and after t seconds
what what has
how much water has come out well
whatever water was here at the beginning
of our time period will now be some
distance to the
will have come out
right and we can kind of imagine a
cylinder here
and what is the the
well i guess in this case the width of
the cylinder
what's going to be the velocity
that the liquid is coming out on the
right hand side
this is a capital v
right capital v is for volume lowercase
v is for velocity so it's going to be
the output velocity that's a lowercase v
times the same time
right
so that's so what is the volume that has
come out in our time t
well it's just going to be this area
times this width
so the output volume over that same
period of time
is equal to the output area of this pipe
times the output velocity
times time
and once again i know i keep saying this
but this is kind of the big aha moment
is that
in that amount of time this cylinder the
volume in the cylinder has to equal the
volume in the cylinder so maybe it's you
know it's not as wide or something like
that but their volumes are the same you
can't get more or less water you can't
get more water here all of a sudden than
what's going in and likewise you can't
put more water into the left side than
what's coming out of the right side
because it's incompressible so these two
volumes equal each other so we know that
the
input surface area of the or the area of
the opening onto the left hand of the
pipe
times the input velocity
times
the duration of time we're talking about
is equal to the output area
times the output velocity
times the duration of time we're talking
about
and if we want you know the time is both
on it's the same time
on both sides of this equation so we
could say that the input area
times the input velocity
is equal to the output area
times
the output velocity and this is actually
called in in in fluid motion this is
called the equation of continuity and it
leads to some um interesting things
we'll do some problems with it in a
second but one thing i want to introduce
at this point as well is
what is the volume per second because
this is also something we're going to
deal with in a second
and probably the next video because i'm
about to run out of time so we we said
in t seconds we have this amount of
volume coming in and it's the same as
coming in is coming out so what is the
volume per second well it's this big
capital v i
per amount of time
and we call that flux and we'll learn a
lot about flux especially when we start
doing vector calculus but flux is just
how much of something crosses a surface
in amount of time how much of volume
crosses a surface in amount of time so
in this case the surface is this
um the top of this the left-hand side of
the cylinder and we're saying how much
crosses in amount of time we figured out
it's that input volume which crosses in
every t seconds and this is called flux
flux
you've probably heard the flux capacitor
in and back to the future and maybe we
can think about what they were trying to
hint at but let's see if we can if if we
can
use flux and the these ideas to come up
with some other
interesting equations
let me see if i have enough time
so we know that the volume per time is
equal to flux this is a big v b is equal
to flux
and actually the variable people
generally use for flux is r and of
course it's it's in meters cubed
per second is its units we also know
that the
input area
area input
times
the input velocity as a lowercase v is
equal to the output area times the
output velocity
which was our output velocity and this
is called the equation of continuity and
it it holds true whenever we have
laminar flow and now oh actually i'm
about to run out of time so in the next
video i'm actually going to use some of
this information to figure out how much
power is there in a system where we have
fluid going through a pipe see you soon